hey constantine do you like christmas no
in ussr we canceled christmas and we had
lenin fest instead hosa we celebrated
glorious leader and rewrote story of
jesus to make it better really yes in
our story three wise men were killed and
gifts meant for jesus redistributed to
glorious workers of the soviet union
jesus was put in gulag for having wrong
opinion as we call it in russia happy
ending
right well if you do want to celebrate
the festive season then there's only one
way to do it grab yourself a ticket to
our final live show of the year at the
leicester square theatre on saturday
december the 11th yes it is discussion
with one of our favorite guests aisha
akanbi she is almost as good philosopher
as vladimir
yeah exactly our two previous shows sold
out completely and this one will as well
grab your ticket now before it's too
late
click on link below during interval
there will be special entertainment i
will ride bear with my shirt off i
didn't realize we were going for that
demographic mate oh yes we are x